the whole social care system is broken
it's broken
karen cooper had three separate home
help providers in just eight months and
all three failed to provide the care she
needed she's one of millions who feel
let down by the social care system she's
now looking to the prime minister for
change
you can't fix
social care
without removing the fear
of losing everything to pay for social
care and you can't fix health and social
care without long-term reform the plan
that this government is setting out
today the plan i'm setting out today
will fix all of those problems together
for the first time in decades a
government has revealed plans to reform
health and social care
and it'll be paid for with a tax hike i
think it's absolutely appalling that the
prime minister who said on his first day
in office that he would fix the social
care problem has done absolutely nothing
the elderly people like me who need care
at the moment we've paid our national
insurance we've paid our taxes we paid
our pensions where is all that money
going we've already paid into the system
where we've been asked to pay again
karen has multiple sclerosis at 62
she'll be dependent on care for the rest
of her life
how that care is funded is crucial
dan archer runs visiting angels the
company that provides karen's care you
can't just throw money at it because
unless the providers working with their
staff unless the people commissioning
and buying care understand how best to
spend the money what you risk doing is
pouring more money into a leaky bucket
as well as setting out who will pay for
care and how much the government says
it'll spend 500 million pounds on
training carers that's crucial because
there's a chronic shortage of staff
right now with more than a hundred
thousand vacancies left unfilled
of the 36 billion raised from this levy
just 15 of it will go to social care
that's five point three billion pounds
and for the next three years at least
the vast majority of the money will go
to the nhs
to help clear the frightening backlog of
operations and treatments delayed
because of the pandemic
homeowners like nicola richards are
desperate now she's lost a fifth of her
workforce this year already
i think listening to the announcement
today we've heard a lot about nhs and
not enough about social care and that's
where the real challenge is at the
moment
we've seen the sector you know
underfunded for decades empty promises
from government and we've now got a real
pressure within the staffing challenges
that we're facing
so i think without the additional
funding hitting the frontline services
which is where it's needed most you know
many providers will not be able to
deliver the care because they won't have
the staff to do
it oh that looks nice thank you very
much
karen needs these reforms to work to be
effective her quality of life and the
quality of life for millions of people
just like her depends on it nick martin
sky news sheffield